bienvenido de regreso disculpa el vídeo
anterior cómo se nos acaba el tiempo
empezamos a correr y comprendo
perfectamente que te pude haber
confundido entonces déjame volver a
explicar ese último ejemplo acerca de la
moneda ajuste que tal vez lo estaba
llamando moneda legal pero pensándolo
bien tal vez la palabra adecuada es
moneda ajuste y nos referimos a una
moneda que no está cargada que si la
tira cien veces más o menos cincuenta de
esas veces van a caer de un lado de la
moneda por ejemplo a hitler y el resto
de las veces que también van a ser más o
menos cincuenta va a caer el otro lado
de la moneda como por ejemplo sol si
estamos hablando de una moneda mexicana
entonces tenemos por ahí a nuestra
moneda justa y la tiró dos veces y
quiero saber cuál es la probabilidad de
que estas dos veces que la tiene me haya
salido águila y águila porque la primera
vez que la tiene me salió águila y
después la volví a tirar y me volvió a
salir
quiero saber qué tan probable es que
haya sucedido eso entonces pues lo que
vamos a usar aquí es algo que se llama
un árbol de probabilidad estamos por
aquí y tiramos una moneda y con
probabilidad un medio no sale águila en
este volado que acabamos de hacer pero
con probabilidad también un medio nos
puede salir sol ok
águila y sol son los lados de la moneda
mexicana así como cara y cruz son los
lados de la moneda estadounidense que le
llaman jets ante gilles pero bueno
estamos aquí con a de águila y ese de
sol
así es que tiramos un volado y con
probabilidad un medio no sale águila y
con probabilidad un medio no sale el sol
entonces podemos trasladarnos a ese
mundo en el que ya tiramos un volado y
nos salió a hitler y ya que estamos en
ese momento en el que ya no salió águila
una vez volvemos a tirar la moneda y con
probabilidad
un medio no sale aguilar en este segundo
volado pero con probabilidad un medio no
sale sol en ese segundo volado ok
y lo mismo pasa si en el primer volado
no salió sol cuando volvemos a tirar la
moneda con probabilidad un medio no sale
águila en el segundo volado y con
probabilidad un medio no sale sol en
este segundo poblado y bueno para estos
ejemplos que son muy sencillos estos
árboles de probabilidad son muy útiles
porque pues tenemos nada más dos
experimentos que es eso de tirar la
moneda y en cada experimento tenemos
únicamente dos resultados no osea
podríamos pensar en esto como unos nodos
y en cada nodo tenemos únicamente dos
ramas entonces es un ejemplo bastante
sencillo y si podemos usar este tipo de
árboles de probabilidad para resolverlo
cuando tenemos 20 experimentos con 50
opciones en cada nodo ahí si este tipo
de árboles
ya no nos sirven de nada porque nada más
nos confunden pero mientras tanto a ver
este es el primer experimento lo que
obtuvimos en ese lanzamiento de moneda y
esto de aquí es lo que salió cuando
lanzamos la moneda la segunda vez ahora
justo lo que queremos calcular ahorita
es la probabilidad de llegar a este
punto ok
porque si llegamos a este punto es
porque en el primer lanzamiento de la
moneda no salió a hitler esta águila y
en el segundo lanzamiento de la moneda
también nos salió águila está otra
águila
entonces si estamos aquí es porque no
salió águila águila ahora cuál es la
probabilidad de llegar aquí pues la
probabilidad de que no salga águila la
primera vez es un medio y una vez que ya
no salió el águila la primera vez la
probabilidad de que nos vuelva a salir
águila es también un medio entonces
tenemos un medio por un medio que y un
medio por un medio es igual
cuarto ahora puedo multiplicar este un
medio por un medio porque estos
experimentos de lanzar la moneda son
independientes entre sí o sea la moneda
no sabe si acabo de sacar águila o sol
en el volado pasado sin importar qué es
lo que haya salido en el volado pasado
va a salir águila o sol con la misma
probabilidad aunque hay entonces estos
experimentos son independientes y por
eso podemos multiplicar estas
probabilidades ahora otra forma de
pensar en este asunto es observar que
cada uno de estos resultados o sea que
nos haya salido águila águila o que nos
haya salido primero águila y después sol
que nos haya salido águila sol o que nos
haya salido sol y después águila o sol y
sol todos estos tienen como que la misma
probabilidad de ocurrir porque cada una
de estas ramas tienen la misma
probabilidad aunque entonces hay
cuatro posibles resultados de los cuales
queremos saber en cuántos de estos
resultados sucede que no sale aguilar
aguilar ok entonces vamos buscando y
resulta que sólo en este resultado salió
allí la jac y le aunque entonces hay uno
solo de los cuatro posibles resultados
en los cuales se cumple que haya salido
allí la hay la entonces la probabilidad
de allí la aguilera es igual a 14 aunque
ya lo pensamos de maneras distintas que
en realidad básicamente son la misma
gata revolcada nada más son distintas
formas de verlo todo pero bueno es
necesario que nuestro cerebro vaya
haciendo este tipo de conexiones bueno
ahora vamos a tratar de calcular otra
probabilidad porque no encontramos la
probabilidad de que nuestros dos volados
salga por lo menos una anguila
y un sol
ok ahora quiero hacer notar que aquí no
estoy diciendo que primero tiene que
salir un águila y después tiene que
salir un sol sino que el orden no nos
está importando aunque tal vez más bien
aquí debe de haberle borrado la coma
para denotar que aquí sí nos importa el
orden entonces y aquí no nos importa el
orden esta probabilidad es exactamente
igual a la suma de dos probabilidades la
suma de la probabilidad de que nos salga
primero aguilar y después sol y ahora si
nos importa el orden más la probabilidad
de que primero no salga sol y después no
salga águila ahora otra cosa importante
podemos sumar estas probabilidades y que
al sumarlas nos quede esto de aquí
porque son eventos días juntos ok si nos
sale primero águila y después sol no nos
puede salir primero sol y después águila
en ninguno de los casos
todo esto de aquí se puede escribir
también de otra forma
utilizando la anotación de los conjuntos
que bueno vamos a escribir la así es la
probabilidad de a s
unión s a que este símbolo de aquí está
es el símbolo de la unión y podemos
pensarlo como que es una o o sea que
estamos calculando la probabilidad de
que pase esto o pase esta otra cosa y
esto es exactamente igual bueno entonces
tenemos cuatro posibles resultados que
son además x probables cada uno tiene
una probabilidad de un cuarto porque
además son cuatro posibles resultados x
probables si hay cuatro de ellos
entonces cada uno tiene que tener una
probabilidad de un cuarto aunque hay
entonces queremos calcular esta
probabilidad busquemos cuál es la
probabilidad de que suceda primero
águila y después sol pues es
un cuarto como todos los posibles
resultados
y busquemos cuál es la probabilidad de
que salga primero sol y después allí
pues también tiene una probabilidad de
un cuarto
entonces es un cuarto más un cuarto son
dos cuartos que es igual a un medio
entonces con probabilidad un medio no
sale por lo menos una anguila y un sol
aunque hay entonces con probabilidad un
medio nos sale una águila y un sol en el
orden en el que salgan otra forma de
pensar en esto es buscar entre todos
estos resultados que son probables y que
tienen una probabilidad de un cuarto en
cual este esto sucede que tenemos una
allí en cuales de esto sucede que
tenemos un águila y un sol entonces por
aquí hay allí la águila entonces aquí no
hay ningún sol entonces no nos sirve por
aquí tenemos un águila y un sol entonces
si tenemos que considerar este caso por
aquí hay un sol y un águila entonces
también tenemos que considerar este caso
y aquí hay sol sol no hay un águila así
es que éste no nos sirve entonces
tenemos dos de estos resultados en los
que hay un águila y un sol y hay cuatro
posibles resultados aquí probables
y es que la probabilidad es igual a dos
cuartos ahora si te fijas estos dos
resultados que tomamos en cuenta por
aquí son justo estos dos resultados pero
bueno ya que estamos en estas cosas
tenemos que ver algo muy interesante
entonces ahora vamos a ver cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener 5 águilas
seguidas
vidas conseguidas me refiero que en el
primer volado nos salía una águila y
después nos siguió saliendo águila hasta
que completemos cinco águilas ok
entonces saber recuerda que las nueve
aunque bueno tal vez te parece lo más
natural pero si no recuerda que la
moneda no tiene idea de qué es lo que
has tirado aunque no es como que la
moneda vea uy acabo de sacar cinco
águilas seguidas ya tengo que sacar un
sol para romper esta racha de cinco
águilas seguidas no la moneda cada tiro
que haces es completamente independiente
a la anterior y por eso podemos
multiplicar la probabilidad de que haya
salido águila en cada uno de los
lanzamientos ahora esto no significa que
nunca nos vaya a salir sol de hecho si
tiras muchísimas veces la moneda lo más
probable es que en alguno de esos
lanzamientos haya salido sol pero bueno
vamos con calma cuál es la probabilidad
de obtener cinco águilas seguidas pues
la probabilidad de tener un águila es
en medio y ya que obtuvimos una hilera
cuál es la probabilidad de que el
siguiente lanzamiento sea ágil pues
también es un medio y cuál es la
probabilidad de que el tercer
lanzamiento sea aguilera pues es un
medio y así nos seguimos cuatro monedas
cinco lanzamientos
entonces tenemos que está probabilidad
es igual a 1 entre 2 a la 5 que es igual
a 2 a las 5 es 32 ahora qué te parece si
sacamos la probabilidad de que de siete
lanzamientos
lanzamientos no nos salga ninguna águila
anguila
aunque ahí suena más complicado bueno
pues resulta que no hay porque si no nos
sale ninguna ley como la moneda tiene
únicamente dos caras a fuerzas nos tiene
que salir sol entonces la probabilidad
de que en siete lanzamientos no nos
salga ninguna águila es igual a la
probabilidad de que no salga siete veces
seguidas un sol pero la probabilidad de
que salga un sol es también un medio
entonces esta probabilidad es igual a un
medio
ahora que estamos lanzando la moneda
siete veces entonces un medio a las
siete y eso es igual a 32 por un cuarto
que es igual a 1 entre 120 8 y con esto
de aquí se puede hacer un experimento
super divertido bueno no sé si divertido
pero por lo menos interesante por
ejemplo si tienes un salón con
muchísimas personas y a todas las
personas las pones a tirar volados si tu
salón es suficientemente grande por
ejemplo si tienes 128 personas en él es
súper probable todavía no hemos
calculado esa probabilidad pero es súper
probable que al menos a una de esas 128
personas le esté saliendo una racha de
soles o de águilas ok que vayan por el
quinto lanzamiento y sólo le hayan
salido águilas o solo le hayan salido
soles y un fenómeno psicológico muy
curioso es que seguramente esa persona
cree que hay algo muy especial con lo
que está pasando en su vida en ese
momento y que tal vez debería de irse en
ese momento a las vegas' por qué
está en una racha de buena suerte pero
pues eso es algo que uno tiene que
pensar más a fondo o sea porque en ese
salón lo más probable es que haya una
persona en la que esté sucediendo eso y
ese es el tipo de juegos psicológicos
que juegan las probabilidades con
nosotros pero bueno ya se me está
acabando el tiempo así es que te veo en
el próximo vídeo